Hello everybody!
I'm back on YouTube!
Yay!
Alright, for those who don't know, we're like, oh my god, Doki, we missed you!
I hope you had a great rest week!
Has not been follow- does not have a Twitter account.
Because we're doing- we're resting.
What is that?
So I'm gonna update the YouTube people who are not familiar with what's going on on Twitter or, you know, on the other streaming platform, Twitch.
Anyway, so basically, if you're like just primarily on YouTube, which is understandable because Twitter's a hot mess.
It's understandable.
What new drama is on Twitter today?
Wow!
It's understandable if you're not on Twitter and you didn't realize what's going on.
And if you're not- if you don't follow me on Twitch, it's perfectly understandable.
Basically, so I joined a Minecraft Twitch Rivals.
And it ended up...
I thought I was gonna be eliminated at best at the second day.
I thought after two days of it, it'll be over.
But instead, I ended up making it all the way to day four with no prize money.
So...
Do not worry!
We're actually getting that compiled into a... into a video.
But it's taking a bit because my video editors are also working on the WrestleTuber.
And also on...
Wait, what was the other...
What was the other thing that I did?
Oh, Tekken!
Yeah!
I'm sorry!
I've had like so many back-to-back-to-back-to-back events.
Legitimate Tekken...
Did you guys know Tekken was like three weeks... two weeks ago, I think?
I think Tekken was like two to three weeks ago, by the way, guys.
But it felt like it happened two months ago.
So...
So we had...
We have two...
I have two editors who do like main videos.
And they're already working on WrestleTuber and the Tekken Sajam Slam.
So that's why like...
The Minecraft video might be a while before it comes out.
Yeah, it was literally three weeks ago.
WrestleTuber was two weeks ago.
And then the Minecraft arc was last week.
Oh my God.
Anyway!
And then we have another announcement this week too.
So yes, before we play the game, it's time to give you updates!
It's update time!
So people who are just here to be like, Doki, we just want to watch you play the game.
Come back in 20 minutes because usually I'm fucking giving updates on life.
So take 20 minutes before I finish giving you a life update.
But yes, we're just trying to give the YouTube people up to speed on everything.
But basically...
Basically, I had four days of Minecraft.
And like, you know, it was 150 people that joined in.
And then I got eliminated at what?
Number 60 something?
67th?
I got eliminated at 67th place.
Spoilers!
I don't care.
I think I literally tweeted it out anyway that I got eliminated.
Like, you know what?
It's day four out of like five days.
Like, come on.
It's 150 people all the way to like one person wins 70,000.
What was it?
Was it $70,000?
Was it?
I always say that out loud, but it's actually fucking crazy that it's $70,000 for first place.
And like people who get...
But like people on day four get nothing.
Day one to four, people get nothing.
It's actually crazy.
I thought I would get eliminated in two days, you know?
Because I joined in thinking like, well, I'm not a Minecraft player.
I'm totally going to get eliminated in two days.
So it's like, that's fine.
Like at best, I'll make it to day two.
And then I have the rest of the week off.
But then I made it to day four.
And every day was fucking wild.
Like it was like a four to five hours each day.
And like it got so bad that actual drama came out of the Minecraft event.
Because people were...
Because some...
Okay, so like the events were very poor.
Like some of the events were incredibly poorly programmed.
Yes, Gumi hard carried me, by the way.
I would have got hard eliminated.
And then Gumi dragged me through the finish line for like three days straight.
It was terrible.
Because, okay, do you know why?
It's because Gumi got invited to Shroud's birthday party.
You know, like Shroud's 30th birthday party.
Where they're fucking...
They were doing that Fallout...
The Fallout themed birthday party.
So she got invited to Shroud's birthday party.
But she had to reject the invite for the Minecraft witch rivals.
And you know at the end...
At the end of it, she was like, I wish I didn't.
She was like, I could have been at Shroud's birthday party.
So she dragged me along to something.
She literally could have gone to Shroud's big three.
I know!
I was so surprised at Shroud's 32.
I thought he was like 40 or something.
I'm so sorry.
But like, I don't know what happened.
I feel like gaming really aged him.
I thought he was 40.
I did not realize he was 30.
He seemed...
I didn't even knew that.
And I was like, his big three?
Oh, he's 30?
Because everyone was like, oh yeah, Shroud's so old now.
And so then I always think like...
I always think he's like, you know, late 30s.
You know, because everyone always calls him old.
Or like, and he's been around for a really long time.
You know, he's been around for so long.
And then just to find out he's 30.
And I'm like, oh my God.
People think 30...
Okay, to be fair, in gaming history...
Okay, to be fair, in gaming, I thought like people...
A lot of people say like, you know, 30 is new old for esports.
And like for esports, which is sort of true.
It's sort of true because all the Fortnite pros are like fucking 13 and everything.
So...
Yeah.
So like, I guess like when you're comparing the young blood, the 13.
And the 17 year old esports pros.
It makes sense.
You know, like 30 is usually the time when like esports players start to retire.
And just become content creators.
Because like you also make more money.
As a content creator as well.
I didn't say I thought 30 was old.
I was surprised.
I was so surprised.
Because that he's 30.
Because a lot of people keep saying that Shroud is old.
And he's been around for fucking decades.
He's actually been around the scene for decades.
I didn't realize he popped off at 16.
Guys.
I didn't realize.
He like popped off at 16.
That's why he's been around for so long.
And so I was so surprised.
I was like, oh my god, he's only 30.
Wow.
Not like, oh my god, I can't believe he's fucking 30 retire.
I mean like, oh my god, he's 30.
That's so young.
Hahaha.
That's what I mean, guys.
That's what I mean.
Anyway.
Um.
But yeah, anyway.
So like, I was so surprised to find out he was 30.
Because he was a lot younger than I thought.
I literally thought he was 40.
Hahaha.
I thought he was a really insane FPS gamer at 40.
I was like, oh my god, that man still has his reflexes at 40?
Holy shit.
Hahaha.
A lot of people would want that.
And then I find out he's 30.
And I was like, oh my god, he is so much younger than I expected.
Because I felt like, I feel like CSGO really, I mean, CSGO and Valorant can age anybody.
So like, I don't blame him.
I...
Hahaha.
He's still got...
I don't blame him.
Um.
What pro FPS dude.
I mean, being put up with like, fucking, like, Cry Baby Valorant.
I mean, I would age 20 years too after that.
Hahaha.
We were talking about Trou.
Um.
Kaz thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
30s is the new 20 guys.
Our life is just starting.
Being 30 is being so.
That is true.
The longer our lifespan, the 30s is practically the new 20s.
Guys, we're not dying at the age of 40 anymore.
This is not like the 1800s.
Guys.
We gotta remember it's not the 1800s anymore.
We can live past 40 chat.
Hahaha.
We don't have to have kids at the age of 15 anymore guys.
We don't have to keep popping the babies out to work in the factories to earn money for the family.
Like, factories can't even employ children anymore.
I think.
Well, certain countries don't do it because of ethical reasons.
Hahaha.
Don't research your chocolate brand.
Um.
Fiction.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
In the past life, I asked you if you can play Spec Ops Align but it's been delisted for some time now so you can unless you find a physical copy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh.
Mitchie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Congratulate.
Congrats to random Vtuber number 13 for making it to the top half.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Anyway, what was I gonna say?
Oh yes.
Anyway.
Uh.
So yes, I was part of this Minecraft Twitch Rivals.
Even after I got knocked off, apparently like day 5 with the finals of the Minecraft Twitch Rivals got intense.
Uh.
So intense that the finals was Connect 4.
Hahaha.
So.
So they try to end.
They try to end.
A $70,000 first place with Connect 4.
So...
And by the way, there was apparently a bug in the semifinals.
There was yeah, the Connect 4 that lasted two hours too, by the way, the Connect 4 lasted two fucking hours.
Because it was so it was so badly planned.
It was poorly planned.
That like, it was like in a standoff.
They were in a standoff because they kept like skipping the turn, their own turn.
They would skip their own turn because they know if they do a turn, the other player would win.
So for two hours, they would both just skip their turn and not place a block.
And then so there was a huge like two hours of nothing.
And then both players were like, we're not gonna play the game.
Just split the first place prize to the both of us.
So in the end, like there was no first place.
They both like they held, I mean, I would do that too.
They held the entire tournament hostage to split the prize money between the two.
I mean, that is so fucking smart.
It's like, it's like a win win for both of them.
They each like, I mean, $35,000.
It's still a lot of money.
Yeah, $35,000.
So the fact that they managed to like hold the prize money.
Hold the tournament hostage and like convince them to give them both $35,000.
That is so fucking smart.
That is actually so smart.
But yeah, no.
And also like there was a huge bug in the semi-finals where there was like it ended up pitting like Spanish speaking Minecrafters against English speaking Minecrafters.
Because like.
There was a huge argument in the semi-finals because one of the English speaking Minecraft players got eliminated due to a bug.
So like the only Spanish speaking Minecraft player left in the entire tournament got through.
So then like, so then all the Minecraft players started fighting about it because the English speaking Minecraft player was like, no, I deserve to have a rerun because I deserve to have a rerun because I clearly was a bug.
But then the admins was like, it's not a bug.
It was ping.
And so then like there was a huge argument and they're like, I demand a, I demand a rematch.
And then, and then the admins ignored them and went straight into the finals.
And then the guy kept, it was so, oh my God, I wish you guys could have seen the discord.
It was actually insane.
It was so bad.
And then, um, um, the biggest Minecraft player that was still in the final day.
That was the biggest Minecraft player that was still in the final day.
Not the finals, but the last 20 players.
There was one really big Minecraft player.
I won't say names, but you guys can imply you were watching the four day event.
You guys, uh, can like, we'll be able to imply on who it was, but the biggest Minecraft player that was still in the last day who were like the top 20 got eliminated or like not eliminated, but there was a chance for them to like get eliminated.
And then it was so funny because Dream was watching his game.
Cause like they were part of the dream SMP.
And so, so like, he was like, it was funny.
It was so funny.
So he was like complaining about it and was like, this was the final day, by the way, he was complaining about it.
And he was like, and a dream was like, invite me to the server.
And then he was like, oh my God.
And I was just, all I could think about was like, like Dream was like, invite me to the server.
Dream is like, invite me to the server.
So I can fight your fight.
This is what I thought, obviously they didn't say that.
But in my, cause I was watching the stream.
Cause I wanted to know what the was going on.
I was just like, oh my God, I want to know what his reaction is.
But like Dream was just like, put me in.
And then the guy was like, oh my God, I'm going to try and get stream into the server.
I must get dreaming server and give his opinion.
Like I was just like, bro, he's like calling his mom.
I'm not a mom to fight his fight for it.
Dad, he's coming for you, kiddin'.
I got it.
It was so funny.
I was watching the fucking...
I was watching his stream and I'm like, really?
You're gonna try and get Dream involved?
Like, what?
Dream, the man with a million controversies.
Like, his only weapon is his fanbase at that point.
I'll talk to my father about this.
I'm just like, holy fuck.
Like, that's so... it was so fu... I don't know.
I thought that shit was hilarious.
I was like, really?
You're really gonna try and get Dream involved?
Oh my god.
Yeah, these are grown men, by the way.
These are...
I just think Minecraft... I think the Minecraft drama is so fucking funny.
There's so... oh my god.
There's someone that's like an outsider looking in.
It is... it's pretty funny.
Oh, shit.
Bro, Batman's a fucking millionaire!
Bro, 70k to that... to like some of the... I don't know if you guys know this.
But a lot of the bigger Minecraft streamers are millionaires.
100%.
Like, there's no way.
They have... they're like 5 million plus subscribers accounts.
Like, they're millionaires.
They have like... they have merchandise and Walmart, guys.
They're Minecrafters.
They literally have Minecraft kids money.
Um...
So like... so like, they don't... they don't... he doesn't need the 70k.
It's just ego.
Like, a lot of the Minecraft players is just regarding the ego.
Um... the famous ones, obviously.
The famous Minecraft streamers.
There's... cause there's a lot of them that are like... not like 5 million plus Minecraft streamers.
But... Minecraft kids money is wild.
It's true.
It is wild.
Um...
Yeah, it's like not... it's actually insane.
So... so like, yeah.
It's actually crazy.
Just like watching the drama in the sideline.
Just seeing like the fights and stuff.
Gumi's not... Gumi doesn't even stream Minecraft.
Primarily.
She's like... she's like Minecraft sideline.
I think that's the perfect way to describe it.
Like the side...
Oh yeah, and then you got all the... it was so weird.
Cause they're always like... they hate... a lot of them hate the games.
Because there's RNG involved.
Um... and like...
Okay, it's like funny too.
Because they're like...
Oh my god.
These games have so much RNG in it.
So that random Vtuber number 13 can like have a chance.
And I was like in the call when they said that.
And I was just like bro what?
That's me.
I made it this far.
Because of RNG.
And also Gumi dragging me through this.
But...
Four!
You can't fucking...
Bitch about RNG.
When the fucking finals is Connect Four.
Letting go.
And the funniest shit was that before the huge two hour delay.
The two hour hostage situation.
All the Minecrafters were complimenting the last game.
It was fucking hilarious.
They were all complimenting the last game.
Until...
Until there was a bug that showed up.
And then everybody turned around.
And was like this game is shit.
This game is garbage.
There's so many bugs.
But then like...
They played two games of the Connect Four.
And everybody loved it.
And then the hostage situation came.
And they were like...
Bro this fucking RNG bullshit.
And I was just like...
Bro what the fuck?
Make up your mind.
I was just like...
Bro...
Make up...
Is it a good game mode?
Or a bad game mode?
Like what is it guys?
I can't tell.
You guys are having a huge mood swings right now.
The switch...
No the thing is...
It's like everybody too.
Everybody was like...
This is a great game.
And then suddenly this huge bug happened.
That eliminated a player.
Because of it.
And then everybody turned around.
It was crazy.
It was...
And it was just me watching it too.
Cause like I didn't have...
It was like my rest day.
Because I don't have to stream day five.
I got eliminated on day four.
So I was just watching all the drama unfold on Discord.
And just seeing like everybody typing like...
Like they were like...
Everybody was like...
It was like they put the Discord on slow mode.
Like throughout the tournament.
Because everybody was just...
It was like several people typing like...
The Discord server was like on slow mode.
It was on a...
It was on a one minute timer cooldown per message.
And then it was like...
I was just like holy shit.
People are angry.
People are so angry.
Doug, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
On one hand, I'm sad you didn't get anything from the event.
On the other, we got to see the most chaotic neutral internet discussion I've seen.
Thank you.
Overconnect?
Boy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Stranger.
Thank you the super chat.
Thank you.
RngCottack4?
My brother in Christ.
You control the fort.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Stranger.
Oh...
Yeah...
It's.
It's so...
It's actually insane.
Oh, my God.
Oh...
Anyway.
I mean.
I have a lot of other life updates.
But just wanted to update you guys regarding.
Regarding.
Why I have...
This is why I've been gone where I was the past week for those who are mostly on YouTube.
This was why I was gone the past week.
Because instead of rest week, we had Twitch week!
Yeah!
We somehow managed to get into Twitch week instead of rest week.
So yeah, anyway!
Alright, for those who left for 20 minutes because they wanted to watch me play the video game, it's time to tap back in.
It's time for Indigo Park, guys!
So, Indigo Park is the new flavor of the month mascot horror game.
What is that, you may ask?
Well, every couple of months, there is always a new mascot horror game.
Because FNAF started... brought in the fad.
So, mascot horror games!
The most famous one is FNAF!
Five Nights at Freddy's!
Then we have Poppy's Playtime!
Then we have the monstrosity Garden of Bon Bon!
Okay!
I'm gonna say it.
Garden of Bon Bon has to be the most...
Has to be like...
I don't know how the fuck that got popular.
Like...
I'm gonna say it.
That game...
80% of that game has to be like...
Acid Flips.
Like I...
Like the fucking mascot themselves!
Like...
Oh my god!
The mascot themselves is...
It's so bad that it's true!
It's so bad that it's good!
Is it supposed...
I'm pretty sure it's not supposed to be a parody chat!
Like... did you not...
I'm pretty sure it's not supposed to be a parody!
Yes!
What are you talking about?
Oh my god!
Okay, anyway...
Yeah, you guys didn't know.
Yes, the person who's right.
The Bon Bon models are famously so high poly...
And trying to load the model will break your computer.
Yes!
The reason why the Garden of Bon Bon is so poorly optimized...
Is because...
The models for the Bon Bon models...
Are like...
A thousand plus polygons or some shit.
Like, I don't know, 30,000 polygons.
It's actually...
It's actually insane.
But anyway, like I said...
It's all about the mascot horror genre.
So now we have Garden of Bon Bon...
Poppy's Playtime...
FNAF...
Benny and the Ink Machine...
They're all in!
The whole...
Every couple of months, we always get a new...
Mascot horror game.
Because that's what kids love, baby!
Wooo!
Scam those children!
And have some...
Really complicated, over convoluted...
Lore!
So that horror channels will do like...
Oh!
Let me do some predictions about it!
Oh yeah!
Then the Amanda too!
Hello neighbor!
Grab those children and get them invested on the...
Over convoluted lore!
Because that's what the children love!
Anyway...
Of course...
I am a content creator.
The Endless Theories.
Yes, the Endless Theories.
And they get a retcon and everything.
And they...
Anyway...
So as a content creator...
I like money.
So I also...
Fall into the system...
Of playing the mascot horror drama.
So here we are...
Testing, trying out the new...
The Slayver of the month mascot horror game.
Apparently it is actually pretty decent.
The matter of slavery...
That's understandable.
Thank you capitalism.
But yes...
So...
People are saying it's sort of like a...
Walking simulator.
Versus an actual horror game.
So like...
We'll see what it is guys.
So...
So we'll see.
We'll see how it feels.
I've never played this before.
Okay I'm gonna like...
Give you guys straight why I never touch...
I will never touch Poppy's Playtime.
I'm gonna tell you guys right now.
I'll never touch Poppy's Playtime.
Because of one incident that happened in Poppy's Playtime.
And...
Very early on.
But the internet forgets.
So like after that incident that happened with Poppy's Playtime.
I will never touch Poppy's Playtime.
It was...
That's why I never...
Never played it before.
I've never played it before.
And I'll never play it.
No it wasn't the NFT incident.
It was something else.
It was regarding like the develop...
I don't really like the devs of...
I don't really like the devs of Poppy's Playtime.
And there was like a huge incident that happened.
Between the devs.
And that's why I would never...
That's why I've never even played Poppy's Playtime.
I've never played it...
Before then.
Before as Doki.
I've never played it before then.
But I'll let you guys know now.
The reason why I'll never touch Poppy's Playtime.
I don't care about the other mascot horror genres.
But yeah.
That was the reason why.
It was like a long time ago too.
This happened like a long time ago.
And that's why I'll never touch it.
Anyway.
Let's play Indigo Park.
Indigo Park.
I loved...
It was so funny because I was listening to the music of it.
And like it's so happy.
Like what?
Oh yeah.
That's why it's called Raccoon.
Alright.
Yay!
Such happy music!
If you guys didn't know.
The Poppy's Playtime dev used to do like...
FNAF animations.
So like they were...
It was crazy.
Before like...
Before they made Poppy's Playtime.
They would do like FNAF music videos.
Hey!
Ahhhh.
Let's see.
Loonimo.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What influenced you into playing this game?
Rana has been recommended a lot.
Doki, I like money.
I almost spilled my water.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey Tengen.
I wish I could enjoy it.
Oh apparently this isn't really a horror game Tengen.
It's more so of a horse walking simulator.
With like...
So like I don't know.
That's what I've heard about it.
Um...
But yeah let's go.
New game!
Are you sure you want to start a new game?
Yes I've never played this game before.
We played FNAF.
I actually played FNAF and I beat it world record.
I had a world record on FNAF.
But I couldn't upload it on the speedrun thing because it's like heavily it's so really programmed that you have to press new game instead of uh instead of like continue game.
So I couldn't get a put it on the world record.
Is this Walt Disney?
But like copyright free Walt Disney?
Is that me?
Oh my god that's my gamer table!
With my one can of World Up.
Don't miss me!
Mom's favorite.
Molly McCaws.
Hey Laura I'm doing another search this week.
Do you want to come with me?
What is it?
The last time I got with you I sucked.
Remember the old... Oh they're like those like um those people like in that MrBeast video where they explored an abandoned island.
They're like those uh Oh it's called Bird Up.
They're like those content creators that explore abandoned places.
There's like one channel that does like exploring abandoned places and they were doing... I saw one of them where they visit like abandoned hospital.
Oh my god that's a YouTube figure.
By the way guys my YouTube figures are coming out like tomorrow for pre-order.
Is it Urban Explorers?
There was one I was watching that was like where they were exploring the abandoned hospital.
It was so fucking freaky.
Okay I think it's fucking stupid that a hospital can be abandoned.
Because like I've seen how expensive hospitals are.
Like hospital equipment are.
So the fact that like a hospital can be abandoned.
I'm like that's where our taxpayer money is going to.
Like that shit is expensive.
There's like an abandoned like MRI scanner.
Like what?
That's like at least a million dollars.
I'm just like this is so fucking unfair.
This is unfair.
Oh my god.
Oh I hope it better be a private hospital.
This better not be a public hospital.
Because medical equipment is so expensive.
Okay.
Apply changes.
Alright I need to make sure.
Well okay the sensitivity is so fucking...
Uh hi.
Alright.
I would be so mad if it was a public hospital.
Is sound guy here?
Sound guy are you on?
If not I'm gonna like.
If sound guy's not here.
I'm gonna pawn off your sound guy job to the other mine.
To the regular mine.
Even though they have like no license to sound guy.
Oh sound guy!
Alright.
Sound guy.
Oh my god there's a lion.
Can I pick it up?
Nice.
Oh information kiosk.
Sound guy's here.
Alright I know like it's not... you're not...
You don't have the degree to do the sound guy.
Woah!
But that's okay.
We're a company now.
Toe Keeper.
Woah!
Toe Keeper Incorporated.
We're not actually a company by the way.
I'm just me.
Sound guy.
You're our first guest in 2,920 days, 4 hours, 23 minutes, and 38 seconds.
Congratulations!
Yay!
Hello Rambly the raccoon.
It's my job to make sure your experience here at Indigo Park is the most rewarding.
Just hop on over to the registration center to your left.
Where our friendly assistant will help you begin your adventure in the park.
Wait who's my assistant?
Press E to interact with an object while looking?
Okay.
What do I do?
I'm gonna interact with a chair?
Hi!
I'm Rambly.
Rambly the raccoon.
And it's my job to make sure your experience here at Indigo Park is registered.
Let me just get a good look at you.
We have to register by PC?
You seem to have your face in our guest list.
Is this your first time here at the park?
Or did you just get plastic surgery?
No worries.
It's Rambly Tuesday.
So you qualify for a big discount on your visit.
Just follow me to the main gate.
I got a discount?
I got a discount on everything Indigo Park has to offer.
Oh my God!
Wait how come the monitors look real- this- okay.
Alright.
This is a little bit nitpicky.
This is a little nitpicky.
This is an old ass telephone.
But this monitor is not an old ass monitor.
If you're gonna acid flip at least make it- I'm joking.
I don't know if they're actually acid flipping.
I don't know.
I don't know if this is like a- They bought some acids on the Unity store.
I won't judge.
I was just joking.
It was not actually judging.
Ooh.
I wonder why this- It is?
Oh!
Is this the gate?
Yeah, it's not open.
Yeah, it's the error message.
Me?
Oh my God.
Oh, I'll bring down the music?
I'd love to show you the audio cause it's just one.
What music audio?
Okay.
It's literally just one audio volume.
Only the master volume.
Okay, hold shift while- Yay, I can run.
Do I have stamina?
No, I don't.
Guys, I don't have stamina.
Guys, I'm built like a fucking god.
It is?
Is it this piece?
Oh.
Where's the piece?
Oh, there's a collectible.
Brambley, where is it?
Brambley!
Oh no.
Oh, there it is.
It's right here.
Okay.
Nice.
I found it.
Yay!
Am I a child?
Look at my child hands.
A children hands.
Okay.
I turned on the generator.
Brambley.
Can I go inside now?
Inside the theme park?
Okay.
For real this time.
Yay!
Alright.
Seems fun.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But Doki, if there's infinite stamina, that means you're gonna be running a lot.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No, that means I won't be running a lot.
Because infinite stamina is here to freak you out when you're getting chased.
So you would manage your stamina.
That's why I feel safer now.
Because when you don't have infinite stamina, then you know you're gonna get chased.
Then you know you have to manage it.
I know how horror games work.
Oh, Brambley.
Every guest needs a critter cuff.
That will allow you access to reserved areas, charge payments to your room, and get a free gift shop.
A critter cuff?
Head in there and I'll get you set up.
Okay.
Please have your critter cuff ready to scan.
How is he able to have power working when the generator's not on?
Where's the critter- Oh, there it is!
The gift shop!
Oh my god, look at all those marketable plushies!
There's the off-brand Mickey.
I assume that's the off-brand Goofy.
Off-brand Donald.
And then...
Dragon.
I don't know, Pete?
Oh, there you are.
Oh, where is it?
Oh, there it is!
I mean, it's pretty sus that he's able to get the TV working.
Um...
Oh my god, my fast pass is here.
TV working when the generator wasn't on already.
Has he always been looking at me?
Oh!
The door mysteriously locked!
Why not test out your band and save the day?
Alright.
You know you can buy that shirt right now.
I think this is why mascot horror games are so popular.
Because the merchandising goes fucking crazy.
Boop.
Hooray!
Great work buddy!
Wait, I'm gonna get my own mascot horror game.
And then you can find me on Hot Topic.
Or like, what's the other version?
There was another, the other Hot Topic store.
The other edgier Hot Topic store.
I wanna be a mascot horror game.
And be on fucking Hot Topic.
For all the pre-teens and children.
Spencers, yes!
Guys, make me so popular that you'll find me at a Spencer.
My new goal is to be in a Spencer store.
Doki, no!
That is my new goal.
You know, I was like, I don't really have any goals anymore.
Except for getting a million subscribers.
My second goal!
I wanna be a mascot horror game.
I wanna have merchandise in Spencers.
This is why we needed Funko Pop.
Cause Funko Pops are always in a Spencer store.
That's a unique goal.
You know, if I'm in a Spencer...
Pretzel dog.
If I'm in a Spencer's, then you know I've made it, guys.
You know I'm a millionaire if I made it into a Spencers store.
Spencers.
You can call me a millionaire if you see me at a Spencers.
Like...
In the front...
Oh my god, of course the front of the...
Never go to the back of the Spencer store, guys.
Jonathan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't go to the back of the Spencer store.
I went to the back...
I went to the back of the Spencer.
What?
There's a loading screen?
What the fuck?
What the fuck happened?
What the... When did this happen?
I loaded screen into a collapse?
Okay.
Alright.
Yay!
Whoa.
Ooh.
The bathroom's creepy.
Ooh, I don't like it.
The sky fell.
Oh my god.
Time to use all my...
I can't use the bathroom?
9 out of 10.
I need to use the bathroom.
Somehow the ceiling collapsed.
Yeah, somehow the ceiling collapsed in the middle...
in the middle of my Spencer's rant.
Alright, women's bathroom.
Knock knock!
I think my character's a man.
Oh hey.
Oh my god!
There's my Funko Pop!
I'm sorry.
My YouTube's pop.
My YouTube's figure.
Ooh.
Look how it's like really quiet now.
Pardon our dust, buddy.
Looks like the park is going through some...
Wait.
It knows?
It's an AI!
Your Rambly Tuesday discount will be...
3% off!
Why not celebrate this great deal with a ride on my railroad?
To test your sleuthing skills, I'll let you find this one all by yourself.
Who the fuck is Molly?
Oh, this is Molly.
I mean, Molly seems like a nice gal.
Oh, what the...
Ah, fuck!
I don't like that.
Bro, I don't like that.
Ooh!
What happened to the happy music?
What?
What's going on?
Oh, is this AI taking over?
Oh...
I don't like how the AI is taking over.
CamRage, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I look forward to the cardboard cutout of Doki Bird displayed at the front window of my local mall, Spencer's.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I mean, they already have...
Oh my gosh, I don't like this.
They already have like random anime t-shirts.
...suggests you may be a bit older than the target audience for this ride.
But it's one of my favorites.
Do you know why Rambly the raccoon loves Rambly's Railroad?
Did you see that?
There was a scary cut.
What do you mean Molly is gonna chase me?
Molly's a nice bird.
She looks really nice.
I don't like this.
Oh!
I'm gonna walk really slow.
She would not do that to me.
Alright, but Spencer's already has like random anime t-shirts.
Just bring in VTubers.
Where are my VTubers?
I like trains.
Yay!
Oh my gosh!
Hello, Rambly's Railroad!
I'm Conductor Rambly!
Hello, Conductor Rambly!
Whoa!
Goodbye, Conductor Rambly!
Oh my gosh!
It's like the Mickey Mouse ride!
Oh look!
It's Molly McCall!
Hey Molly!
You sure are, Molly.
Why, you only crashed into six bars this week.
I'm not crashing!
What's barnstorming?
Yeah, what's barnstorming?
Oh god, that's me!
Molly,
no!
There's the sun!
Molly!
You're AirPodron!
Oh, goodbye, Molly.
Oh hey!
There's a beach!
Oh, I don't...
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, it's a dragon.
Okay, I didn't like the...
I didn't like the...
I didn't like the whole...
You've known me for one hundred
years for a new seashell from my collection.
Oh, it's a sea dragon!
It's a Loch Ness!
It's friend-shaped!
Come into it instead.
My ride, Oceanic Odyssey, will teach you all about the wonders down the ocean.
Oh, they're introducing each special ride that the mascots have.
I know, I thought it was Eeyore.
He seems like Eeyore.
I'm so lonely.
Oceanic Odyssey currently closed for repairs.
Nooooo!
Oh...
What happened to...
Why did I get off?!
No!
Oh no!
I had goosebumps!
I have goosebumps!
Oh...
I did not consent to getting off the ride.
Oh, the door opened by itself!
I love that!
Oh, I'm so happy!
Don't you love it when the game...
Oh!
I have goosebumps right now!
Oh, I don't like this.
I actually have goosebumps right now.
Oh...
Oh hey, there's Molly!
She seems nice!
She seems nice and totally not gonna get back up.
Right?
Oh hey!
There's Lloyd!
Where would the gear be?
Oh, there it is.
In front of me.
Oh, there's two gears?!
Oh my god!
This is bad!
I'm too stu...
Oh, there it is!
Oh, I don't like how I can hear rambly on the background.
Makes me so uncomfortable.
Hey Molly!
Are you gonna be getting up now and chasing me?
Molly, are you okay?
Goodbye Molly!
Oh, look at that!
Oh, goodbye!
What happens if I die?
Like, do I have to redo the entire thing?
There's no way, right?
Ugh!
Whenever I'm in a loading screen, I know I'm safe.
Oh hey!
It's...
Oh my god!
I remember Lloyd!
That's professional!
People started drawing!
Adult art of him already!
Just like Tony the Tiger!
What?
You know the Tony the Tiger thing that happened?
Where like, people started getting horny for Tony.
That like, the guy who played Tony the Tiger got so uncomfortable that he just stopped...
...VTubing.
So, where do you wanna go?
I don't know.
Wait, is that Molly?
Wait a minute.
That looks like Molly.
Oh, I wanna get my expensive...
...Rambly ears!
That shit is like...
...$50!
I want one!
Ooh!
That's a swamp!
Ooh, the water is not looking so good.
Oh yeah, she wants my autograph.
That's true.
She heard I'm gonna be on a Spencer's.
It's very...
Spencer's!
If anybody is like a relative of a Spencer's executive...
Call me.
My...
My email is...
Tell them that like...
They won't regret it.
There must be one person...
...who's like a cousin...
...of a cousin...
...of a Spencer's executive.
There has to be one Dragoon.
The author of...
...Lifetime.
Alright.
My business email is...
...Doki can't read any...
...execs in chat.
Oh, over here?
Oh my gosh, the clock is freaking out.
This here is an information kiosk.
Okay.
If there's anything around the park you wanna ask me about...
...just stop by here and I'll ramble on about it.
Hmm.
I always need help.
Oh, a mommy plush!
She's always been my best friend.
Did you know she builds planes...
My dad's name is Spencer.
Does that count?
Oh, I can just talk about...
Oh my gosh, the...
...the...
...the U2's figure.
Oh, I got this.
I know the commercial by heart.
Wow, it's the unlimited edition...
...Grammily the Raccoon Raction figure.
Push him down and he jumps.
Push him up and he doesn't.
Only $19.99 at your favorite toy store.
Only $19.99?
What a fucking steal.
Well, since it's an abandoned theme park...
...it should be even more expensive.
People love...
Collectors love that shit.
When things get abandoned...
...and the prices are like...
...triple the price.
Is this a pizzeria?
Or a restaurant?
Well, there's no reason for me to be at the restaurant...
...so let me just move forward.
I don't think there's a reason for me to be up there.
Not so deadpo...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
I'm scared.
I don't know where to go, guys.
Uh...
The only doors open is the restaurant.
But what if collectables?
This looks like a pizzeria.
Where the fuck...
Didn't I supposed to have a friend with me?
What happened to my friend?
That's supposed to go to the abandoned place with me.
Caf de...
...Rachon La Vie.
Guys, don't judge my French.
Oh, is there like collectable in here?
Oh my god, there's still pastries in there.
Oh...
Mold flavor.
Can I bring that?
Nice.
Alright.
Is there anything else in there?
No, it's just garbage.
Chocolate.
How much is it?
A chocolate cookie is $4?
For one tiny fucking cookie?
A Subway cookie is two Canadian dollars.
Bro, what a fucking scam.
A caramel apple is $9.50?
That apple...
better come from a fucking apple tree from the president or some shit.
Like...
That's one apple.
This is so stupid.
Disney Land prices.
Like, why...
Bro, that apple...
better be grown on some fucking famous person's backyard.
For $9.50.
No wonder it was closed.
Bro, what the fuck is a Rambly Special?
Jesus.
It's not even an enchanted apple.
How fucking dare they.
Maybe I should go to the...
Lloyd's Theater.
Lloyd seems like a cool guy.
I wanna go to his...
theater.
Wait, I can't?
But I have the Fastpass!
Oh my god.
I think Rambly hates Lloyd.
He purposely not gave me...
a Fastpass for Lloyd.
Can't believe it.
God damn it, Rambly.
It's not my fault that...
Lloyd is better.
Lloyd is like the Donald Duck of Disney.
People like Donald more than Mickey.
And Mickey hates that.
Snooks, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Can you get me a Rambly Special?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I guess it's here, right?
Yeah, the reason why people like...
Oh hey, another collectible.
The reason why people like...
uh...
Donald more than Mickey is because...
Disney has made Mickey so fucking bland now.
Because he's like a...
What is it?
He's like a blank canvas.
Where like, um...
He has to be like super child friendly and everything...
with zero personality now.
Look at that!
You're at Jetstream Junction!
Yeah!
Looks like Jetstream Junction is being tuned up!
Donald can actually have a personality.
Maybe a friendly Wrangler can help you get in!
Mickey Friendly Wrangler?
Who the fuck is a friendly Wrangler?
Rambly!
Who's a Wrangler?
What the fuck does Wrangler even mean?
I don't know your lingo!
Isn't the latest Mickey cartoon pretty neat?
Do you know when that Mickey cartoon came out?
They don't do those anymore.
I don't know if they do those anymore.
That was like...
10 years ago.
I want a cookie you can keep the one dollar.
Gary, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
You know the one word that Mickey was like, What happened?
That episode was like...
I think like 6 plus years ago.
Can I use this now?
I can!
Yay!
I can go to Lloyd now!
My game crashed.
Fuck!
Rambly!
Why can't I visit Lloyd?
Rambly does not want me to see Lloyd!
The moment I wanted to see Lloyd, Rambly pulled the plug.
I can't believe it, Rambly!
Let me see Lloyd!
Yay!
Okay, I loaded into Lloyd's world.
Whoa!
What the fuck?
Lloyd, are you okay?
Whoa!
That's a real lion!
Wait a minute.
Guys, I think this might be a horror game.
That's a real lion!
Who the fuck let this lion in here?
It's real?
He just brought in a real lion and then put a shirt on it.
Did they like put a shirt on a lion?
Hey buddy, I've got eyes all over the park, but I can't see anything behind the stage.
If you're going back there, be careful.
Your critic card was not in the game.
I'm not able to resuscitate you.
Not able to resusc...
Not yet.
What happens if the lion kills me?
Hello?
I should start running.
Ooh, I should stop running.
Ugh.
It gives me the ability to sprint, but I don't feel so good.
I know I can sprint, but I just...
I feel like sprinting just feels wrong.
It feels so bad.
It feels so wrong.
Alright, let's bring the one volume...
Okay, we'll bring the volume slider down to...
Our one volume slider down to 75.
Why is it one volume?
Where are the other volumes?
Let's see.
As long as there's no blood on the floor, everything's fine.
It's just old cardboard boxes.
There's no blood on the floor, so like...
The park is very safe, chat.
That's when you know the park is safe.
There's no blood.
That's my point of reference.
If nobody dies, then we're okay.
What is that ambient?
Bling!
I don't like that.
Oh, hey dude.
Oh, that's a big Lloyd statue.
Lloyd?
Hello.
Hey, Lloyd.
Hey.
What the fuck?
Bro, what the fuck?
There's Lloyd.
He doesn't seem so bad, guys.
Guys, I don't know.
He seems pretty friendly.
He looks like he just wants a hug.
He's a little embarrassed, guys.
He's a little embarrassed.
Bro dipped.
After getting crushed by like empty cardboard boxes.
Like...
Those boxes seem like empty too.
It's not like an actual box filled with stuff.
Hey, hey, hey.
Where's Rambly?
Did I just walk backwards?
I guess I just walked backwards, right?
Free hug.
Got me a free hug, guys.
I don't know.
He seems extra cuddly.
Doesn't seem so bad.
Neppers, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm just like, hey, Lloyd.
Do you want another hug, Lloyd?
Wait, do I have to...
Wait, this is a new area, right?
No, this is where Lloyd came out.
I'm pretty sure.
I want Lloyd to hug me.
I wanna see what happens.
Like, do I get reset fully?
Or does he just stop and was like, you're supposed to run.
Or does the game just make him stop because you're confused.
Because you're like, wait, a regular player would just run.
I want that.
I wanna take that home and sell it on eBay.
That shit might go crazy.
Lloyd seems like the type of character that must have like, a lot of like, uh...
What's it called?
Occult following.
I feel like Lloyd seems like the occult following character.
Where like, his stuff can go for a crazy amount of money.
Alright.
Beep.
Whoa, Lloyd!
Hey, Lloyd.
Ah, fuck you little pussy.
What the fuck?
You fucking bitch.
What a little bitch boy.
Lloyd.
Wait, where's my flashlight?
Did my flashlight stop working?
Where was I supposed to go?
Did you try- How do I- Oh, there you go.
I was like, where did my light go?
Alright.
What just happened?
I don't even know.
Wait, he touched me and was like, Oh!
Look, look, I've been urban exploring for a very long time, guys.
Okay, it's not my fault.
Okay.
It's not my fault.
I haven't had time to go home yet, guys.
Please take a shower.
It's not my fault!
Urban exploring is a hard job.
Sometimes I don't have time to take a shower.
It's physical, God.
Donkey, don't put- Don't shame.
It's 2024.
Shake my head.
Thank you for the super chat.
Alright, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Why are you so harsh on him?
He's just trying to say hi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello, bitch.
Like, what the heck was that?
Mascot horror games.
In my back, guys.
Guys, we're not bullying Lloyd anymore.
I'm sorry to Lloyd.
Okay.
Regarding update on the new PC.
I am like 80% done setting it up.
Guys, I'm 80% done.
Guys, I'm 80% done setting up the new PC, guys.
I promise.
It's almost done.
I was moving fast.
I was moving the files, okay?
I didn't have time to finish moving the files.
But also, I deserved that.
I'm so sorry to Lloyd.
I...
I apologize to Lloyd.
I'm so sorry, Lloyd.
I did not mean to bully you.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry for calling you a pussy.
I'm sorry.
Because technically you are a pussycat.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean it, Lloyd.
Please let me at least finish this game.
So I think my PC is like about to die.
Because if you guys were not there for the Zen Amelie collab.
Because I didn't stream it.
But like I did tweet it out.
But like my PC was like...
crashing and blue screening almost every game.
So then I was like...
Oh, I think...
I think it's time to retire this game.
I think...
I think my PC is finally at its death bed, guys.
So I was like...
Slowly...
Not slowly, but I was actually...
Because I still have like a million other projects I'm working on behind the scenes as well.
So I've been like moving files and everything.
Oh, this is horrible.
No!
Molly!
You know what I think?
What I think I need to do?
I do not think we need...
I don't think we need Epic.
She crashed to Molly!
No!
You should have also got a new PC!
Hey!
It was Lloyd's first time interacting with a girl and you laughed at him.
Are you thinking of the Super Chat?
Thank you.
Say!
Why don't you check out Molly's landing pad?
It's not far from here.
And it's a great cool down after that exhilarating ride.
Just take a down from Molly's rooftop races.
Just take a down from Molly's rooftop races?
What, like here?
Alright.
So yeah, like...
I swear guys.
I will...
Tomorrow...
Wait.
That's Molly.
That's my plane.
Wait.
Where do I go?
Do I go this way?
Zy!
Thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you!
Yesterday was my birthday.
Thank you...
for being an inspiration as a gamer and streamer.
After all these years and months.
I enjoy my time here.
Feeling laughter and smile.
I just turned 32.
Oh my god!
You're older than Shroud!
Thank you for the Super Chat, Zy!
Thank you!
Oh my god!
You're just like Shroud!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Zy!
Oh shit!
Now we're back to...
FNAFing time!
Do I need to...
actually know this puzzle?
Oh no, this is FNAF.
Bum bum bum bum bum bum bum...
Bum bum...
Do I just turn it until it works?
I don't like this!
This song is too happy!
I feel uncomfortable!
Just put a random fucking...
What?
Oh...
Oh no...
Oh now I'm definitely uncomfortable.
Oh...
Oh no...
Oh I can feel like Molly is definitely gonna come here.
Oh come on Molly!
That's not cool!
Molly!
This is not cool Molly!
You can't just chase me while I'm running!
Damn my man got roasted on his birthday!
Hey guys thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you!
Molly?
Molly what's wrong with your wings?
Bro Molly!
Molly I'm your biggest fan!
Molly get over here!
Don't be a little bitch like Lloyd!
I'm sorry if I crash again because I said that.
I'm so sorry.
I feel like I'm gonna crash again.
I'm sorry for calling Lloyd a bitch.
There I go.
I guess I'll go here.
I hate this.
It's so scary.
Oh wait I'm back in the beginning.
What the fuck?
Am I supposed to...
Is this a maze?
Oh I have to figure it out.
Wee!
Alright guys what's the answer?
Hey guys wouldn't it be so funny if you helped me out here?
Wouldn't it be so funny?
Guys I don't wanna film!
I don't wanna go to the maze!
I hate this.
I hate these.
This is so stupid!
I fucked up the maze!
Okay.
God I hate Molly.
Molly nobody loves you.
That's why I said it Molly.
Nobody loves you.
That's why...
Everybody loves Lloyd.
Cause at least he has a personality.
What's your personality Molly?
Ow.
Where did I go?
Where am I?
Oh wait I die?
What?
I just die?
There's stars.
Oh there's a red star!
Is that clue?
The lethal ball pit.
Okay we're all...
We don't play these games.
We play RTS.
Thank you for the super chat Ivan.
Thank you thank you.
But they're bringing it back!
They're bringing back RTS Ivan!
Just for you!
Okay.
Red star.
Alright we got one of them.
Oh guys remember.
Green triangle.
Red star.
Remember that.
Oh god.
I'm not good with physics.
What the fuck?
Boom!
How?
Oh my god.
Doki is failing a child's game.
Red star.
Green triangle.
Alright.
Blue star.
Okay.
Red star.
Green triangle.
Blue star.
Oh hey!
Hey Molly!
Why are you looking at me like that?
Okay I hope you guys remembered all of this for me.
Red star.
Green triangle.
And then...
And then what?
What's the last one?
Blue star.
Okay.
Blue star!
Yeah!
Okay.
I didn't like that sound.
Did you guys hear that sound just then?
I didn't like that.
Molly?
Molly where are you?
Molly just grab me already.
We know you're gonna grab me Molly!
Molly?
We're back here?
Oh, I don't like this.
I don't like this at all.
What am I suppo- oh.
Molly?
Did I do it?
Oh, I did it.
Molly?
Molly coming out from that door?
Oh!
Hey.
Guys, Molly's not coming from that door.
What the fuck?
That was no- bro.
Molly can repeat words, don't be fooled.
Repeat what words?
What the fuck?
That's my play.
She did not look like that.
I was like, that was not what Molly looked like.
Damn.
Bro, why is Molly scarier than the fucking...
...than the fucking lion?
I don't know.
I didn't realize she was behind me.
Alright.
I have to go here.
It's not fair, my back was turned.
Here we go.
That's fucking right.
That's right, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
AHHHHH!
NOOOO!
That's not fair!
Might as well not even run!
Might as well just walk!
That's so bullshit.
Bro, I hate these types of games.
That's so bullshit!
Oh my god.
How did she get there?!
Okay.
Left.
Alright.
That's good to know.
That's good to know it's set pathways.
Left!
Alright!
Woooo!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh no.
I fucked up with this one before, didn't I?
Alright, she's not gonna appear here, right?
Oh nice.
Okay.
Alright, I gambled correctly guys.
Oh my god, I'm so smart.
I gambled correctly guys.
Guys, I need you guys to remember the pathways for me guys!
AHHHHH!
This is bad.
This is so bad.
Where am I?
I don't know where I ran off to.
NOOOO!
I jumped into here!
Bro, this is where 80% of the game is.
I got baited!
I'm so lost!
No!
Okay.
Alright.
That one was so unfair.
It was.
It's so unfair.
Okay.
Left.
Left and right.
And then what?
Left again, right?
It's left and then left again.
And then was it left again?
And then it was left again, right guys?
Okay, it was left again.
Why is she so fast?
Molly, leave me alone!
It's not my fault you're not popular!
Bro, improve yourself!
Oh my god.
It's not my fault kids don't love you!
Oh no.
Okay.
Nice.
Parkour.
I was never gonna make it anyway!
What are they?
Okay.
Alright.
We...
It's forward, right?
The jump goes forward.
Yes.
Okay.
The jump goes forward.
Alright.
Oh.
Okay.
Up.
Up I go.
And then down I go.
And then we go this way.
And then we go that way.
Alright.
Nice.
Your merchandise just doesn't sell, Molly!
That's why we don't make more!
Oh god.
Please don't come up here.
I'm still running!
Oh god.
I don't like this because I can't see in front of me!
I can't see in front of me!
Oh, there you are!
Oh, am I safe?
Am I safe?
Wait, hold on!
This room's staff only!
I'm staff!
I have...
I have no friends!
My...
What?
Okay, right?
It closed.
Oh okay.
Nice.
WTF?
Bro, it's not an animatronic?
Holy shit.
He's real.
Oh my god.
There's blood!
Why is it fleshy?
I thought they were supposed to be animatronics!
Okay.
They're real?
Remley, there's a dead fucking bird on my floor!
Yeah, I'm having so much fun.
Sure.
Yeah.
Ooh, I don't know.
Working with an AI?
Terminator taught me that I shouldn't be doing that.
Oh, okay.
Do I just...
Whoa!
Guys, you hear that?
The trademark expired!
That means we can take it and make... It's like the Mickey Mouse really boat.
Scene boat.
We can make our own content!
Our own Remley content!
We go here?
Wranglers only?
I'm a Wrangler.
It's public domain!
Well, technically not public domain, but it doesn't have a trademark.
Is there any freaky dolls outside?
No.
Yeah, every ball of security seems fine.
Let's make a Remley horror film!
That's what people do when a fucking trademark goes expired or things go public domain.
People just make horror films.
Because it's the cheapest.
Alright, let's head up.
Yay!
We made it!
We survived!
We survived, guys!
So easy!
Oh, who's this?
Who's Pluto?
Oh, it's the Pluto!
Wait, she doesn't seem to be an Indigo plush.
Oh, it was in Lost and Found.
Damn, Remley!
That's fucked up!
At least that Pluto might just be a toy.
We still have a franchise.
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you!
Fun fact, ball pits and playground city castles used to exist.
Wonder why they all disappeared?
Germs.
Covid.
Oceanic Odyssey?
I did it!
I did it.
Go in?
There's nobody here.
Can I go in?
There's a lot of loading screens.
Not gonna lie.
Is that it?
Oh, it has its own song!
Bum bum ba ba.
No!
At Indigo Park, there is a stark contrast to everything I know this place should be.
But out of the dark, you've given a spark of sunshine to this kingdom's faithful devotee.
At Indigo Park, more than my remarks are mysteries.
Even I don't know what we might find.
But fight for the dark.
And I'll be your spark of sunshine to get you out of any bind.
That is, if you want to keep going.
Oh, idea!
I know all of this isn't fair to you.
It's an awful lot to ask.
This song is nice though.
It's a really nice, like, song in general.
Yeah, that was it!
I heard it was like a really short game.
Like, because it's chapter one.
I mean, it's free, by the way.
This game is free.
Which is better than, like, you know, other mascot horror games that make you buy each chapter, including chapter one.
So, like, you know, I'm glad it's free.
Yeah.
For free games?
You have to buy chapter one of Garden of Bon Bon, chat.
I'm pretty sure, like, chapter one's free and then it hooks you in for, like, a couple of weeks.
For people who like mascot horror genres.
And, like, um...
And then they make you buy chapter two.
Yoki cover when koala.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's actually surprising.
When I uploaded the...
When I uploaded the short...
Sorry, shark.
The short for a friend like me, people didn't realize I sang that in karaoke.
So, people were like...
People were like, oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, my god!
Upload the full song!
When did you sing this?
I'm like...
Two months ago?
I was just like...
What?
Two months ago?
I was just like, what you mean?
Like, upload the full cover.
I'm saying that like a long time ago.
It's still there!
I mean, that was enjoyable.
I mean, it is a full passion project.
I mean, like... I'm gonna say it...
It follows the mascot horror game formula.
So if you like mascot horror game, you'll like Indigo Park.
It's very... it works!
The formula works!
People make like 5 million theories already!
I swear if I like YouTube like...
If I YouTube like Indigo Park theories, there's gonna be like 5 million theories already.
But like I feel like it works so... so like that's why like these types of genres is like really popular.
And like clearly Indigo Park is like...
It's a genre that works really well.
Like it follows the mascot horror genre and it works very well in that aspect.
Oh shit!
It's the devs in my chat!
Main writer, voice actor of Lloyd and Isaac, and composer of half the songs including the Rambly review.
Hope you enjoy the first chapter and thanks for playing!
Thank you!
Thank you for coming over!
So watch my playthrough!
Oh my god, bro!
Bro, Lloyd fucking... I'm sorry for calling Lloyd a little bitch.
And then he like made my PC blue screen after I said that.
I'm sorry.
Now I'm a Lloyd fan.
Thanks for coming over!
I don't know if you saw that part.
I didn't mean it.
Lloyd's my Oshii now.
Lloyd's my favorite character in Indigo Park.
He put me in his place.
But like yeah, it's a free game.
And um...
It clearly sets up a lot of like...
Like the story building and everything.
And like...
They're real.
I think they're real!
When Molly's head came off and there's blood everywhere.
That seems so real.
I think they're real creatures, guys.
But yeah, you can check it out.
It's for free.
It is like episodic.
So like I don't think I'll be...
I don't know if I want to play it.
I don't know.
Maybe I'll play chapter 2 when it comes out.
Just for like FOMO.
You know, like everybody will be playing chapter 2.
So then I might as well experience chapter 2 with all of you guys when it comes out.
So yeah!
It's a free game.
So like it doesn't hurt.
And I assume that chapter 2 and the rest will be paid.
Just because like that's usually how it goes when it comes to mascot horror games.
But yeah.
Let me go back to my chatting screen.
I enjoyed it so far.
The lore building.
Because it's the usual type of...
It's there to like hook you in.
And to be like, ooh what's going to happen next in Indigo Park?
How did the park get abandoned?
Why is that a real lion?
Why is there a real lion in there?
And not a fake lion.
Where did the real lion come from?
There was an arcade.
Oh my god.
I missed a lot of stuff.
I didn't even realize there was an arcade in there.
Apparently I missed a scene where something was supposed to happen.
And I wasn't looking at it.
That's a little bit of a shame.
That happens a lot.
Final next.
Okay, Indigo Park.
What's his name?
The Eeyore Dragon?
What was the Eeyore Dragon's name?
Eeyore... what was his name again?
I just remember him as Eeyore Dragon.
I know Molly's name.
Oh, Finley.
Okay, Finley.
Ending.
Alright guys, I'm going to watch it.
I'm going to steal the content.
Where is he?
He's like here, right?
Alright.
Here you go.
I'm looking at the ending.
Alright.
Oh, there he is!
Why didn't I see that?
Bro, he just... okay.
Is that the jump scare?
He just flies over.
He just fucking swims over.
God.
I didn't realize that was the jump scare.
Alright, so that was the jump scare.
I thought there was like other...
I thought he was going to do something.
Well, that's nice to know.
That's nice to know.
Oh, there's the arcade.
Oh, if you beat the arcade game, things go freaking crazy.
The Arcade Machine Rambly Rush is where most of the rest of my music was.
There's also a fully animated official music video of the Kredits theme on my channel.
Oh, shit!
There's a fully...
Oh, nice!
The music was really good.
I really enjoyed the music.
I see it.
Here's the music.
Yeah.
There you go.
If anyone wants to check out the full music...
But yeah, thanks for dropping by.
Thanks for dropping by.
I'm glad to be able to play your game, sir.
Oh, best.
Alright, super chat reading time.
Guys, okay.
Alright.
I promise you guys this today.
I will set up my PC.
Like, I'm not gaslighting this time.
Because I'm 70% done.
If tomorrow...
The PC is not set up by tomorrow's Sandland stream...
You get to request anything as a group from me.
One thing.
You get to request anything...
As a group, though.
You guys have to agree as a group, though.
You have to agree together as a hive mind what you want.
I didn't think it was super easy.
Thank you, chat.
Thank you.
But I will...
I will set up...
the PC by tomorrow.
Before the Sandland stream.
So we'll finally be free.
We'll finally...
Visage was already gonna be played anyway, chat.
It was already gonna be played.
We reached the goal.
Did we?
Yeah, we did.
We reached the goal.
We reached the charity goal.
So, like...
Look, see, I'm so generous.
I could have lied.
I could have lied and was like, Oh, I don't know about Visage.
Alright.
Well...
Guys, I like how you're all coming up with ideas now.
Not believing that I'm gonna set up my PC.
I am going to set up my PC!
By tomorrow!
So you guys...
So don't even need to think about it.
You guys don't even need to think about...
Like, the podcast.
Like, the punishment.
Cause it's gonna be done.
Chat.
That's the thing.
If you're thinking about it now, it's a waste of your time.
Kaz, another Doki karaoke.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
We heard that one.
But this time!
Look, because blue screen is a little bit too much.
If like the game crashes like once every once in a while, that's fine.
But the blue screen is sort of the...
The blue screen is where I have to draw the line.
That's when I know that my PC is literally begging.
It is like crawling itself to the grave right now.
My PC is literally just crawling to its coffin.
And like, please bury me.
Please, I beg of you.
I am blue screening.
Bury me.
Leave me to die.
Like, that's when I know...
That I have to...
I have to let it rest in peace for real.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Eldering and Visage.
Cosmic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's been weeks, Doki.
Look, that's what I'm saying!
I am finally going to make sure my PC is finally left to rest.
Because it's literally at its dying knees right now.
Wanting me to put...
You know like that...
There's a hole in front.
The PC dug its own hole.
Gave me a pistol.
And was like, please, just end it.
The blue screen was a sign.
It's never blue screened before.
When all the problems were having...
When we were having all these problems.
But now that it's starting to blue screen...
It is time...
To lay it to rest.
Zai, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
QV, thank you for the super chat.
Alright, best, spin the bossa reel if it isn't ready tomorrow.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, stop coming up with ideas!
What do I get?
When I set it up, chat.
What do...
A working PC.
Okay, that is true.
I get a working PC.
But also, what else do I get?
But there should be...
More!
Okay, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
I had a great time hanging out with you guys.
We're back on YouTube!
Yeah!
Anyway, guys.
I'll see you guys tomorrow.
It was a short stream today.
But it's more like an appetizer today.
Because we do have a sort of long week filled with lots of streams.
This week.
So, uh...
If you don't set tomorrow, you have to eat more hot sauce.
Thank you for the super chat.
Joke's on you!
I like hot sauce!
I'm Asian!
We can handle the sauce!
Anyway, guys.
It might be a short stream today.
But like I said, it's sort of like a little appetizer for the long week of solo streams.
I had a great time just talking with you guys again.
Just like to the dragoons mostly.
So, like, collab.
It's a great time to just have dragoon time with you guys.
But, yes.
I'm gonna finish saving some...
Migrating my files and everything to the new PC.
So I'll...
I fucking felt like I had a stroke there.
Like, I couldn't...
I couldn't verbalize.
My words were just tangled up.
Anyway.
I'm gonna go head off now.
As always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!